The SCP Foundation’s hallowed halls have
been the site of many great and puzzling mysteries.
Among them being, who was the true creator
of SCP-173, the neck-snapping Sculpture?
What are the secrets that Dr. Alto Clef is
keeping about his past?
Who are the true seven children of the Scarlet
King?
Who was SCP-106, the Old Man, before he got
all nasty?
And of course, what is the true nature and
origin of SCP-096 - The violent, terrifying,
and incredibly withdrawn Shy Guy?
It’s a question so great that we knew even
our experts here at SCP Explained couldn’t
take on the mission alone.
That’s why we pooled the resources of you,
the loyal viewers of SCP Explained, to find
the answer.
We made a community post asking for your personal
theories on how the Shy Guy came to be, and
you didn’t disappoint, sending in a cavalcade
of curious conjecture that we just can’t
wait to explore.
So let’s hop right in and see what all of
you had to say!
Here is PuffyShade’s theory:
“He was a lost British D-class named Martin
McGregor.
On a risky experiment in Columbia regarding
SCP-1290, a D-class prisoner was teleported
to an unknown mountainous location after a
malfunction in the device.
He stayed there for 37 hours before dying
of his bullet wounds from being shot by foreign
soldiers.
Wherever the D-class was teleported to was
a foreign country not welcome to outsiders.
As we all know, there have been some SCPs
that have escaped the grasp of the foundation.
The foundation has located them, but never
been able to see or capture them.
Continuing with the story, it is speculated
that one of these entities that is still undiscovered
had the power of necromancy.
They brought the D-class back to the mortal
world, but in an immortal form.
To terrorize humanity forever.
The entity brings humans back to life as supernatural
beings, their powers being determined by their
former personality.
The resurrected D-class was always shy, self
conscious of his unattractive face.
As you can probably guess, this resulted in
the birth of our good old friend,
Shy Guy.”
Certainly a fascinating direction to go, with
a basis in recorded anomalous activity.
And much like a few other anomalies originating
from D-Class personnel, such as SCP-2419,
the Laughing Men, and SCP-4973, the Dead Men
Walking, it would feel oddly satisfying to
see another one of the Foundation’s greatest
mistakes become one of the gravest threats.
Here is DiamondStar Lemon’s theory:
“The Shy Guy was Andrew Irvine, one of 2
mountaineers that went missing who were part
of the British expedition that was sent to
reach the top of Mount Everest in 1924.
While Andrew and his friend George Mallory
were heading for camp 5 , they encountered
SCP-1529 at different intervals.
Since Mallory's body was eventually found
in 1999 this tells us that Irvine also encountered
1529.
Irvine constantly rejected 1529's offers and
eventually developed a defense mechanism where
he gets aggressive and attacks SCP-1529, in
return
1529 prolonged his life by years to make him
suffer every single minute.
His skin turned white due to constant exposure
to the sun and he took off all of his clothes
due to hypothermia.
This is confirmed because Mallory's body was
just as white as Irvine and a letter he sent
to his family says that Andrew became very
shy and barely speaks and he eventually disappears.
Mallory then encounters 1529 and punches him
in the face and then Mallory falls unconscious
leading to his death.
Meanwhile Irvine loses his sanity and has
his body disfigured and his hands developed
claws for better climbing.”
This is another popular theory which has its
roots in pre-existing anomalous knowledge.
The horrific tortures by SCP-1529, the Mountain
King, against Andrew Irvine is believed by
many to be the root of the Shy Guy’s creation.
Of course, we can’t know for sure, but some
compelling evidence undeniably points in this
intriguing direction.
Here is #1 Try Hard’s Theory:
“I think he was one of the subjects in the
Russian Sleep Experiment that escaped and
ran into the Siberian mountains, became aware
of the monstrosity he had become, and became
violently self conscious.”
This is a strange and creative theory, wrapping
096 in with the lore of the legendary Russian
Sleep Experiment.
Russia does have its fair share of snowy mountain
ranges, and the experiment did turn its unfortunate
subjects into horrifying monsters.
But the nature of these monsters did differ
significantly from the Shy Guy - showing higher
intelligence, but far less durability against
physical trauma.
Here is Avery Spencer’s theory:
“I have wondered if perhaps he was part
of an almost Dyatlov Pass incident and was
the sole survivor.
Being in such a position he was forced to
eat his comrades.
He then took on almost wendigo aspects, but
instead of the blood thirsty feelings most
got he became so ashamed of what he did he
can no longer tolerate someone looking at
him.”
This is another incredibly interesting theory
that has its basis in both Russian legend
and real life history.
There have been a number of events in the
snowy mountains of Russia, much like the Dyatlov
Pass Incident, which have left high-altitude
tragedies in their wake.
One of these, traumatizing its victim to the
point of turning them into an anomalous creature
like SCP-096 definitely doesn’t seem out
of the question.
Here is Kyreikal’s theory:
“Shy Guy has no face.
His face does not exist.
Not in the sense that its just smooth skin,
the face is actually nothing.
He is a body and mind directly attached to
a pattern screamer.
Humans expect humanoid shaped creatures to
have a face.
Thus when someone sees his "face" the screamer
takes over and destroys that person so it
can stop existing.
His body has changed over the years to facilitate
eliminating people who see the "face" more
effectively.
This is why he wants to dissappear in the
desire camera, finish being nothing so people
stop filling in his face.
A way it could have happened is an incomplete
encounter with 3930.
The one who became the shy guy leaned in and
just his face ceased to exist.
Though he probably would have already needed
some anomalous traits to survive that.”
This is another extremely original and interesting
theory based in pre-existing anomalies.
Of course, there’s no real way to prove
that SCP-096’s face isn’t a pattern screamer,
given that to look upon it is to court death,
so we may just need to take your word on this
one…
Here is Lacintag’s theory:
“Perhaps 096 is an alien from a planet or
dimension that's completely dark, where being
seen is a death sentence because of the local
anomalous fauna.
He somehow wound up in our universe.
Perhaps 096 is cursed that whoever sees him
will eventually transform into something much
worse, or become a portal into a dark dimension.
And he does us all a favor by eliminating
these people before that can happen.”
Another two extremely interesting theories,
both of which could potentially hold water.
They seem consistent with the fact that SCP-096
takes no pleasure in the killing of its victims,
it only seems to be doing it out of the sense
that it feels compelled into action.
Here is Chill Me’s theory:
“He could be the physical embodiment of
the feeling of body dysmorphia.”
Another very valid theory, given SCP-096’s
general temperament and caustic reactions
to being perceived in any way.
Here is Renan Roman’s theory:
“What would happen if Dr Bright looked at
scp 096's face?
I mean, his host would certainly be killed,
but what would happen as soon as Dr Bright
picks another host?
Would scp 096 instantaneously charge at the
new host and kill it as well?”
An interesting theory, and one that we’ve
explored ourselves on videos concerning Dr.
Bright before.
It’s another good reason that this particular
scenario should be placed on the “Dr. Bright
is Not Allowed” list.
Though even though Dr. Bright does occasionally
beg for death, this is one horrifying recursive
fate that even Jack himself probably wouldn’t
enjoy.
Here is Hon Guy’s theory:
“From what I heard there are two theories,
one was the he was a mountaineer that survived
an encounter with the king of the mountain
and had to adapt to the mountain to survive
both from him and the mountain itself or he’s
actually one of the children of the Scarlet
King.”
While we’ve covered the Mountain King theory,
this Scarlet King theory is all new.
Could SCP-096 be a child of the terrifying
Scarlet King?
He’s certainly destructive, but perhaps
he lacks the true knowing malice - the sadism
- that’d make that big, red, armored lunatic
proud.
He certainly doesn’t have the abject hatred
of a 682.
Here is Clawed Cat’s theory:
“I wouldn't be surprised if he was a species
and came to be that way as it is perfectly
hidden.
They blend in with the snow, and if anyone
saw its face to know it was there, they couldn’t
document it for obvious reasons.”
This is an interesting and terrifying concept.
A whole species of Shy Guys.
This is another good reason to ardently fight
against climate change - If all the snow melts,
there’ll be nowhere for them to hide anymore…
Here is Dan Wolf’s theory:
“The idea of "if a tree falls and no one
is around to hear it..." is his origin.
He is the physical manifestation of the energy
of all the things unseen, the sound of a falling
tree, the transparent skin of fish in the
abyssal zone, development on Halflife 3.
All these things exist but they do so UNSEEN.
SHY is physical manifestation of that metaphysical
energy, he didn't exist until he was seen
thus he came to be.
Existing is painful to him so he kills anyone
who sees his face, the thing we as humans
use to identify one another, in a hope to
be unrecognized and unknown to eventually
no longer exists.”
This is a fascinating theory.
Our one question is how he could ever be seen
if, by definition, he is an avatar of the
unseen?
What would cause these lapses in non-existence?
It raises an interesting metaphysical quandary
in and of itself…
Here is Jonathan Collier’s theory:
“The Shy Guy is a creation of the Plague
Doctor, who engineered him in the French Alps.
He began as a human, but the doctor's process
mutated him into his current form.
He designed him to destroy the pestilence,
but he was infected by it somewhere in the
process.
This means that whenever someone sees his
face, they catch the pestilence.
His programming can't allow this, so he is
forced to destroy whoever sees him.
The doctor's programming was incomplete when
he was corrupted, so he only hunts those that
he has infected with the pestilence, not all
that the Plague Doctor deems infected.
His indestructible form is a combination of
the Plague Doctor's tinkering and treatments
as well as the doctor potentially incorporating
DNA from other anomalous creatures, such as
682, which did visit France in Lord Blackwood's
tales.
The doctor likely kept the DNA in reserve
for his ultimate device to destroy the pestilence,
however it failed and led to him releasing
the Shy Guy to roam the mountains, traveling
eventually from the Alps to the Himalayas
where he was discovered.
The creature cries as it kills it's victims
because of it's human beginnings, and it's
apparent anxiety is likely the lingering emotion
it felt before it was transformed, leading
to it being repeated for the rest of it's
existence.”
We love the Plague Doctor here at SCP Explained,
so we’re always happy to consider fun potential
crossovers featuring him with some of our
other favorite anomalies.
The one thing working against this theory
is that 096 is an uncharacteristically effective
creation for the Plague Doctor’s standards,
most of which are janky, disfigured zombies.
Sorry, 049.
Here is Devon Linder’s theory:
“I always felt like 096 was possessed by
an evil spirit that lives in the frost, essentially
the original native story of a wendigo.
It just all makes sense, deformities and strength,
lives in the cold, hunts and kills people.
I don’t know if there’s anything about
looking at a wendigo in the original stories
though.”
The Algonquin myth of the Wendigo certainly
does have some similarities to SCP-096, however,
it has a little more in common with another
anomaly - SCP-323, the Wendigo Skull, which
forces its wearers into spontaneous acts of
violence and cannibalism.
Though if ever 096 found itself wearing the
Wendigo Skull, we’d all be in terrible trouble…
Here is EpicKitty 101’s theory:
“Not really a theory, it's just what I want
it to be.
I believe that 096’s actions are derived
from trauma.
It could very well be a species and might
be a different version, like albino so whenever
someone looks at its face it feels as though
that person was so inconvenienced by its looks
it wants to kill them because he thinks they
hate him now.
He believes he isn't good enough for anyone's
standards.”
We can all relate to that feeling now and
then.
And the hysteric crying and wailing of SCP-096
undeniably suggests a level of psychological
trauma.
One thing we know for sure: It definitely
inflicts trauma on the rest of us.
Here is Lemon Demon Danganronpa’s theory:
“Hear me out: When Day Breaks was actually
a primitive event, and the Shy Guy was the
result.
Without any people to go around for the next
several millennia, The Shy Guy grew fond of
the lack of company, ultimately turning him
into the person-or monster-he is today.”
This is a fascinating one, however, there
is some pre-existing evidence - such as the
tale Unexpected Light, which we’ve covered
in a video on this channel - that suggest
SCP-096 survived into the reign of SCP-001
When Day Breaks.
Though sadly, according to that tale, he didn’t
survive beyond it.
Here is Andrew Colon’s theory:
“I have a theory that he was born with some
deformities and super strength and was mocked
for it.
As he grew older the deformities grew more
noticeable.
So maybe the years of trauma and abuse or
what not have caused him to self isolate and
attack violently against anyone who sees him.”
This definitely reflects the internality that
many people believe SCP-096 has: A frightened,
insecure creature, spiting its own creation
and anyone unfortunate enough to look upon
it.
Though we’ll never really know how exactly
it got there…
Here is Stripeysox 101’s theory:
“He could have been one of the SCP-1000
instances but born hairless and unable to
think, so was abandoned by its parents.”
Another good cross-anomaly connection, however,
096 is significantly more durable than any
member of SCP-1000, as well as having far
more freakish proportions, so it’s unlikely
to have any real relation to this advanced
species of apes.
Here is Blue Iblis’ theory:
“Well based on his height, his reaction
to his face being seen, and how quick he is...
SCP-096 is literally just an IRL Enderman.
They're both tall, they're both able to move
quickly, and become instantly pissed if you
look at their face/eyes.
This probably means 096 is maaaybe from another
dimension, but its just a theory.”
We might dismiss a potential Minecraft influence
out of hand, were it not for the existence
of SCP-4335, also known as A Welt In The Crucible,
an evil Minecraft monster.
However, this monster was actually the one
responsible for the Ender Men in Minecraft
due to a Foundation-inspired patch, sadly
invalidating this theory.
Here is James Bevan’s theory:
“My theory is that the Shy Guy is a demon
summoned by a cult that dwelled in the mountains.
They hoped to control him, but were unaware
that the entity reacts violently whenever
anyone sees its face and all met a grisly
death.”
SCP-096 is undeniably rather…
Demonic, so we couldn’t argue with this
theory on that front.
It’s also very likely that any cult who
unwittingly summoned him, without the knowledge
of his primary anomalous effect, would meet
a truly gruesome death at his claws and teeth,
so you may be on to something here, James.
Here is Harrison O’Leary’s theory:
“Well, when he left the mushroom kingdom,
he obviously lost his mask and clothes.”
The idea that the Shy Guy is literally, well,
a Shy Guy, is certainly an intriguing one
- though how 096’s long, gangly body could
fit into those tiny, compact outfits is an
open question.
If only Researcher Mario and Researcher Luigi
would take some time off of their extremely
busy schedules to help us out with this one…
Here is Roninski’s theory:
“He was a very handsome man who was experimented
on, and now goes into violent fits of rage
when people look at his now disfigured face.”
Hmm.
Is it just us, or is the idea of a strangely
handsome SCP-096 somehow even more disturbing
than the one we already have?
Just feels so unnatural…
Which of these wild theories do you think
was your favorite?
Do you have a stunning revelation we haven’t
covered here?
Feel free to let us know down in the comments.
And of course, keep an eye on our community
tab for fun new questions if you too want
the chance to be featured in a video like
this in the future!
Now go check out “SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE
- Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach” and
“SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy Guy
in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” for
more of this singularly enigmatic anomalous
introvert!